this campaign is really to it's two
parts it's first of all to get men to
reflect
um and you know this campaign doesn't
put men in that perpetrator bracket it
asks that the whole film
from the start starts to look at
language and words
so we're asking men to reflect on past
current behaviors and make the
connection between other forms of
violence and abuse but then we want men
to have the courage to speak up to speak
to their friends use that friendship i
suppose to call out bad behaviors and
you know calling out is quite
confrontational i want men to call their
friends and make that connection before
you speak to them
um
what is it that men actually i mean it's
difficult to to ask isn't it but what is
it that men are doing wrong is it just
that they need to communicate with each
other more
i think it's important you know it's
important we start to ask why we're
seeing these issues and you know most
men in this world
don't
um commit these types of offences but
often you know more often than not we
remain silent you know when we see these
offenses our boys and men are growing up
in this toxic culture and if you look at
the impact of pornography modern
pornography where men win and women lose
it's misogynistic and violence
something's going to happen so for me
um you know it's in the air that boys
and men breathe and we just want to
start that conversation not to you know
target boys and men but to see them as
the solution to these issues
and to that end i mean i've been reading
what you've been saying you and
certainly the videos saying that sexual
violence starts well before you think
what do you mean by that
well you know
just after the celebrate case i was
asked by my my brother about you know
how can i prevent rape and murder in
this country and i said to her stop
thinking about these types of acts and
start thinking about the language the
words the it's often excused as banter
and you know the research says that if
we just allow these things to continue
with no interruption
you know we will see other forms of
violence in more extreme forms so the
interruption just comes from speaking to
your friends and it's not about waiting
for things to happen you know all men
every single day can talk about these
issues i know men feel deeply passionate
about what's going on they're really
upset annoyed angry about what's
happening so simply by talking about
these stories you set the norms for your
peer group
yeah so you uh are agreeing that it's
men uh talking to each other about what
they should uh what is and it isn't
acceptable but what about having that
conversation in school as well
you know i know across the country
there's some great work going on in
schools to have the very conversations
that you have just discussed there in
scotland we have the mentors and
violence prevention programs that we set
up in the violence reduction unit
and is now led by
the education scotland i'm supporting
some of the violence reductionists in
england and wales to set the same
program we're having conversations
bringing boys everybody into the
conversation as the solution you know
prevention of any issue starts in a
community whether that be a town a city
a workplace or within groups of men we
are a community and if we talk about
these issues more and more we will start
to better understand the healthy views
that men have
yeah um and i suppose
very timely to point out
that uh police services up and down the
country also need to look at their
behavior
this this campaign as i said before
focuses on all men um and i think yeah
you know we are seeing you know some
police officers who are deeply concerned
about what is going on and my my ask of
them is to speak about these this
campaign you know call in these
behaviors if you see them in your
workplace this applies to all men not
just police officers all men in all
types of organizations